these were Dennis mcgrory's injuries
photographed by police hours after
Jacqueline Montgomery's rape and murder
it was evidence of her fighting for her
life said the prosecution no said
mcgrory he claimed he'd been beaten up
by four men
in 1976 he was cleared of murdering
Jacqueline she was 15 his partner's
niece
an Old Bailey judge ruled there wasn't
enough evidence and throughout the case
but nearly 50 years on advances in
forensic science prompted a new police
investigation
a swab from Jacqueline's body was
retested and showed allegedly a billion
to one match to mcgrory's DNA
the director of public prosecutions
ordered a rare second trial of a man
declared innocent at his first a
circumstantial case suggesting that
mcgrory had been at the scene of this
murder became a compelling scientific
case when DNA linked him to the body of
Jacqueline Montgomery that's what made
the big difference here
Jacqueline lived with her parents in
North London a rundown area that's been
gentrified since
police say mcgrory turned up looking for
his estranged partner Josie she deserted
him Jacqueline let him in Jacqueline's
body was found by her father Robert when
he got back here at two o'clock in the
morning she'd been stabbed beaten around
the head and strangled the state of the
room showed there'd been a struggle
pages of Jacqueline's diary gave a sad
insight into her Teenage life
being dumped by a boyfriend
her mum leaving home
her aunt Josie leaving Dennis mcgrory
and being given police protection
when he was arrested mcgrory had on him
a page ripped from Jacqueline's diary
that evidence too was given to the new
jury what bears on my mind and the minds
of the police and the CPS in bringing
Justice in this case is Jacqueline
Montgomery those who mourn her those who
loved and knew her for whom 50 years may
seem a long period it may seem like only
yesterday to them and that's what it
motivates us
Jacqueline lived with her parents in
North London a run-down area that's been
gentrified since
police say mcgrory turned up looking for
his estranged partner Josie she deserted
him Jacqueline let him in mcgrory had
always denied being Jacqueline's killer
now a life sentence is automatic but the
judge must set a minimum number of years
he'll be sentenced in the New Year
Martin brunt Sky News North London